does it bother you or scare you at all
when trumpet you know has been known to
address you directly on Twitter you were
saying hey you know doing the Trump
character has been draining you you
don't feel real good about it anymore
it's a tough thing but you're gonna
continue doing it you said I'm gonna
continue doing it because I'm waiting
for the good stuff to happen when he had
impeached that was my response to him
yeah yeah he wrote and he called you
Alex yeah with an X yeah is that
intentional you think on his part to get
your name wrong who cares
yeah don't you think that's a way of
kind of putting you down hey we I don't
even know your name you're not important
but he knows your name sure right he
knows why he owes my name huh Milania
yes your parent parent I'm told she
loves to but we've had more now war more
than one person now a second person has
come to us and said yeah it's true she
watched SNL she'd watch it online and
said she said she laughed and she said
that's him that's him someone told you
that two people - peep - very powerful
people in Washington who know trumpet
know intimately they were there in there
they were in there
you're smiling as you say that you love
that right I love it
you love the how the otherwise I mean
his wife must be my wife is on to me
more than anybody right my wife no one
gives it to me like my wife she knows me
she kicks me in the balls like you can't
believe so you ain't telling so Milan
either her secret passion is that she
watches you she must know yes she must
know what I would have one of them
maniac Kia's and what a weird got here